welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar precision
medicine for mice digital biomarkers
transforming drug discovery it is
presented by Laura Chaffetz PhD the
chief scientific officer at vayam my
name is Judy O'Rourke and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
bobrucz is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow a process to obtain your credits
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Chaffetz I will now
turn the presentation over to her thank
you Judy for that fantastic introduction
today I'll be talking about precision
medicine for mice and how we have vayam
our thinking about digital biomarkers as
a way to transform how we do drug
discovery during this this presentation
I'll be covering a number of different
topics and just to give you a preview of
what that looks like
we'll be defining digital herb
biomarkers and then what's the
difference between a biomarker and a
digital biomarker in addition I'll be
going through some use cases where we'll
look at how high frequency data captured
through digital biomarkers provides more
objective sensitive and meaningful
readouts of disease
the better translate to clinic and in
that section I'll actually be showing
some data from clinical studies as well
as some of the work that we've been
doing in the animal models to show how
some of that can actually translate
directly and then finally I'll spend a
little bit of time on how we're thinking
about the future challenges and
opportunities especially around digital
biomarkers and preclinical disease and
how we can potentially continue to
improve preclinical studies and their
translate ability into the clinic so I
wanted to start with what are biomarkers
and this definition comes directly from
the biomarkers definition working group
from the NIH here biomarkers our care
are classified as a characteristic that
is objectively measured and evaluated as
an indicator of normal biological
process pathogenic process or
pharmacologic responses to a therapeutic
intervention and why are they so
important and to talk a bit about that I
wanted to bring up one of our standard
views of how drug development happens so
here you see a very standard timeline in
which you start very early on with
thousands of compounds in an early drug
discovery phase those lead candidates
will then get taken into the preclinical
phase so you'll have a much smaller
number of compounds in the preclinical
and then only the best from preclinical
will actually be transferred into
clinical trials and at the very end when
you've started with tens of thousands of
compounds you end up with potentially
just one compound that goes through FDA
review and approval biomarkers play a
really important role in this drug
development process because in essence
think again biomarkers are ways of
tracking whether or not a drug is having
a positive effect on a particular area
or a mechanism
action and so what many have done are
actually looked at particular ways of
measuring whether cells are reacting and
those same cells could be the cells that
are within animals in the preclinical
phase and those same responses can be
also monitored in clinical trials so
this is a way of being able to marry
from basically at the beginning of drug
discovery high-throughput screening all
the way through clinical trials whether
or not a drug is affecting a target in a
way that it is expected so in essence
saying meddigan this now provides you a
measurable way to look at the effects of
your investigational drug throughout the
whole development process so you know if
it works all the way back in the drug
discovery section or area phase that it
should work in preclinical and then of
course in clinical trials biomarkers are
really important and there are a number
of consortiums that have been created
including a joint FDA NIH Leadership
Council in order to identify what's
required for a biomarker what those
endpoints should look like and how to
quantify them and validate that they are
effective all the way from you know
again early drug discovery through the
clinical trials generally biomarkers are
thought of as busy some physiologic
characteristics that can be monitored
but mainly their molecular and action so
for example looking at specific
molecular markers all the way through
the cells into the humans but there's
this new class which is starting to
emerge which we called digital
biomarkers and I throw up here a
definition which is not an accepted or
standard definition because to date
there is no unified definition of what a
digital biomarker is but what you'll see
here digital biomarkers are physiologic
and behavioral measures collected now
through connected digital tools
that are used to evaluate those same
processes so we're talking about
biological processes pathogenic
processes pharmacologic responses to a
therapeutic intervention for example now
the key here is through connected
digital tools and digital biomarkers are
generally thought of primarily in the
clinical space and actually on this next
slide I can show you there's a huge
ecosystem of wearable and implanted
sensors which are digitally connected
and the way we think about digital
connection is actually through your
smart phones or your computers and so
these are sensors or wearables that are
on your body that transmit all of that
information continuously or at high
frequency to your smartphone up into the
cloud where it can be looked at more
broadly so this is just an example from
Nature Biotechnology paper published in
2015 of all of the different digital
biomarkers that are out there and
currently under development so you can
see things like being able to monitor
eek aid or ECGs heart rate respiratory a
glucose for example or even compliance
of taking pills so there's a sensor
inside of pills that will tell you
whether or not a pill has been ingested
at the appropriate time so we have this
whole ecosystem of digital biomarkers
that have started to be developed the
question really is how do we use that to
better understand disease and how we can
potentially in a precise way affect
individuals so on this slide I've showed
just a few examples of papers and the
where these digital biomarkers are
coming from so you'll see in the top
left-hand corner here we're looking at
can you identify stage of multiple
sclerosis
I'm using just physical activity
monitoring or can you look at chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease by
listening to the sound of a person how
they sound when they're actually
breathing can you look at heart
using ECGs that you in this example you
actually put your fingers on two little
pads and it measures the ECG now of
course the Apple watch will do that for
you as well and then there are also some
work done in Parkinson's disease where
simply you tap a the iPad this is just a
few examples in many many different
therapeutic areas sensors are now being
used to see if we can learn more about
the disease the progress and identify
better ways of actually diagnosing and
again seeing whether or not there's a
therapeutic response when given a drug
turns out that many of these digital
biomarkers exist in the preclinical
space today as well
we just haven't previously thought of
them as digital biomarkers so what are
some of those examples we can monitor
physiology in rodents as well as in dogs
through implantable sensors telemetry
systems so what I'm showing you here is
a DSi system although there are many
different systems out there that do that
where we can measure ECG or EEG body
temperature glucose readings again these
are implantable sensors and you can get
this information from the animal pretty
much continuously over a defined period
of time we can also look at metabolic
parameters in these animals so here's
just one example again there are many
companies with these systems here we can
measure oxygen consumption carbon
dioxide production a respiratory
quotient food and water intake
information on wheel running activity
body mass sleep time sea
you can see how these are directly
correlated to what we would potentially
be interested in and measuring in the
clinic we can also monitor specific
behaviors so here's a clever system an
IVC rack from them where we can measure
a number of different specialized
behaviors such as drinking or foraging
and the percentage of time that they do
each of these and then the last system
is actually a system that I've been
directly involved in developing and this
is a smart caging system where we can
monitor both behavior and physiology and
so here we can monitor motion breathing
rate wheel running star KD and rhythms
associated with that real wheel running
as well as well as starting to work on
being able to in real time read out
information on those animals so when we
think about these two types of systems
the data that you're getting from the
humans from their smartphones and their
watches they're fitbit's as well as the
data that we've been collecting for many
many years in animals and in-home cage
monitoring systems such as those that I
showed you here or telemetry where were
you looking at ECG the idea here is that
we can actually start to better bridge
the gap between preclinical research and
clinical research by actually looking at
the same behavioral or physiologic
outcomes between the two and so if you
focus on the right here is our here's a
digital twin concept so the idea is
we're taking all of these biomarkers
from the human here we show respiratory
rate cardiovascular activity neurologic
metabolic we take those readings from
the mouse in exactly the same way using
exactly the same types of technologies
we have diseased models for the mouse
diseased models for the human we can
build potentially better models and be
able to track better
from early on whether a mouse is having
a positive response to a drug that would
hopefully help us better predict again
whether a human would have a positive
response from a drug so today I want to
focus on two case studies the first is
in multiple sclerosis and here in humans
we've talked about or their papers out
there on how activity levels or step
counts can help predict disease severity
and I'll show you some data that we've
started to gather thinking about the
same problem in mouse models of MS and
then the second is in a rheumatoid
arthritis model and in rheumatoid
arthritis and again in the human there
have been a number of studies looking at
how of five times sit-to-stand tests
actually predict stiffness and pain in
individuals with rheumatoid arthritis
and we're going to look at in the rat
model of rheumatoid arthritis are there
similar measures that we can assess that
would help a better develop or build
better models that we can then test our
compounds against so starting in
multiple sclerosis let me tell you about
a study that was published in the
Journal of Digital biomarkers just this
last year the study was a fairly simple
one the objectives were to advance the
literature on use of free living
physical activity tracking from MS
patients so these MS patients wore the
Fitbit one Wireless activity and sleep
tracker which you see over on the right
side of your screen there were a hundred
and fourteen self-selected patients they
uploaded their data from the Fitbit one
as well as they self reported on their
multiple sclerosis reading scale which
included a number of different features
such as ability to walk upper limb
function vision speech swallowing
memory cognition sensation burning and
pain here we'll be focusing primarily on
the results from walking but also more
generally from the multiple sclerosis
rating scale so just go right to the
right to the end or what they found what
you can see here is that step count
well predicts disease severity in this
particular example in MS patients so
I've just pulled from a single figure
from this paper but here age of the
individuals is not different gender is
not different disease duration is no
different in terms of overall step
counts so here you can see age and then
those numbers in the column the 3,000
4,000 5,000 s are the number of steps
that that individual or that group had
taken on average once you get down to
the the MSRs this would be the multiple
sclerosis rating scale you can actually
see that there are statistically
significant differences as you move from
the individuals that were reported the
least disability up to those individuals
who reported the highest disability so
specifically here you can see that those
with the least disability walk on
average around almost 6,000 steps
whereas those who are in the highest
disability quartile are walking on
average around 3,000 steps so almost
half as much and then if you further
break that down into specifically how
they rate their walk score that actually
pulls apart even more and you can see
those that report no disability around
the ability to walk report taking almost
sixty seven hundred steps versus those
who have moderate disability are taking
only around 2700 steps so here it's
quite clear that just the number of
steps that these individuals take fairly
well indicates how disabled they are or
they report being what's even more
interesting is that the predictive power
increases even more when the authors of
this paper actually average step count
over multiple days so this is a really
important piece and we'll talk about it
as we get into the animal data as well
but many of us have days of higher
activity and days of lower activity and
so the idea here is that if you actually
average the step count across multiple
days two days four days or seven days
you'll get a better sense of an
individual and their overall activity
levels but that means that you can't
gain this type of data unless you're
actually collecting it continuously in a
lot and you gather lots and lots of data
on the same individual over time and
this is where the digital biomarkers
really show how important they are this
is not information that you can get from
a patient who visits a clinic on one day
as an example so now if we move on to
the animal models let's look at how
these digital biomarkers ie step count
in the human can potentially translate
to what we're seeing in the animal model
so here I'll show you data that we've
collected in our own lab on the Cooper's
own mouse model Cooper's own is a model
in which we feed the animals
Cooper's own which is actually a metal
it causes rapid demyelination and and
then followed by remyelination as you
actually remove the animals from the
Cooper zone it's a model that's commonly
used to assess
kind of Ramayana Schnoor to steady
remyelination it recapitulates many of
the characteristics of ms pathology but
it does not in one key critical
difference here is it does not have an
autoimmune component so what I've just
put up on the screen is a timeline just
to give you a sense for how the
experiment was run and what was measured
at any given time so here we have an
acclamation period so we always want to
bring animals into the facility and get
them used to the facility because what
we find is that they in the first few
days their behavior is not normal so
again it's just as we were talking about
with the humans give them a little bit
of time to get used to their surrounding
then we put all the animals on either
Cooper zone Chow diet or a controlled
diet and we monitor them for six weeks
and then at the end you'll see data
where we've actually removed them and
put all animals back on a control Chow
now in a model like this you would
typically measure one of a couple of
things you might measure body weight you
would likely measure a behavioral assay
so much in the same way as we've just
talked about step count being important
in patients with MS you would expect
that you should be able to see motor
deficits in these animals and that might
be done on either rotor rod or in an
open field and then you might also do
histology for the purposes of today I'll
just focus on the behavioral assay and
the one that I'll talk about here is an
open field assay in which you actually
take an animal and put it into a big box
which you can see on the the right or
sorry on the left of the screen and the
animal will run around the box for
somewhere between usually 15 minutes all
the way up to an hour you'll often
measure the distance that the animal
travels and then
speed at which they travel around the
that box it would be done infrequently
so you might do it once over the course
of a study you might do it a couple of
times it's also usually run during the
day time when an animal or a mouse in
particular would not often normally be
awake so you'll wake them up and then
put them in this box and it's a novel
environment so you can also imagine
there might be some differential effects
by the fact that the animals are
exploring this apparatus as well so when
we look across studies here's just a
smattering I took a quick look across in
the literature and you can see and I've
shown you here on the Left we have
studies we're comparing normal aminals
to animals that are folks fed Cooper's
own excuse me they show significantly
reduced activity in the form of less
distance traveled around the open field
in the middle there are many papers in
which there's no change in the activity
levels in these animals so whether it be
by speed or by the path lengths
conversely there are also a few studies
out there in which when you compare the
control animals which is a bit hard to
see but those are the ones in though the
darker black lines to those that
received Cooper's own chow those of
course are they the lighter gray lines
there they're actually those on those
animals on Cooper's own are more
hyperactive than animals unnormal Chow
so you know when we talk about
reproducibility and animal research and
whether or not you see a positive
response to a compound when the
literature shows such varied responses
it's it's really quite challenging to
know which is true and if you see a
positive effect of your drug where you
don't see a positive effect how do you
interpret that data
so what we did in our lab is actually
put these the same model into this home
cage system so here we bring animals
into the facility and they go directly
into the system we are monitoring
continuously again the motion breathing
rate and overall activity levels on
these animals continuously throughout
the whole entire let's see nine weeks of
the study it's not really a novel
environment except for in that first day
because after that it becomes a fairly
standard environment for them except for
in the case of cage changes we can run
them during the daytime or the nighttime
we can look at data continuously here
again we're looking across the whole
span of the study and rather than
looking at just 12 hours duration now
we're looking at the full-on nine weeks
so what I'm showing you here is data
that we collected specifically just
after case changes and we changed the
cages every 14 days so to orient you to
this those the dark grey lines are those
animals on coupon control Chow excuse me
and the light blue are those on the
Cooper's on Chow we're looking at the
average daytime motion so again trying
to compare it to you what has been done
in the open field where you see the
dotted lines that first dotted line is
where we transitioned from control Chow
and all animals to the Cooper zone or
the control and then that second dotted
line is when we transition all the
animals back off of those that have been
on the Cooper's are now off of the
Cooper's up shop and what I hope you can
see is in the very beginning when we
look just at the response after the cage
change only there's
real difference between the groups then
when you get out 14 days and after being
on Cooper zone Chow we actually start to
see some suggestion of hyperactivity in
those animals on Cooper zone Chow so
this matches that last data set that I
had just showed you and then when we
take the animals back off of the Cooper
zone Chow again now now they appear to
be somewhat similar to the control Chow
animals but if we take into account all
of the daytime data that we've collected
on these animals so here now you can see
all of the data averaged during the
daytime that pattern of hyperactivity
seems to go away so if you compare here
now the majority of the days between
cage changes there's maybe some evidence
of hyperactivity but for the most part
the animals move around very little in
comparison to those cage change days and
it seems to be very similar between
those animals that were on the control
Chow and on the Cooper's own show so now
potentially we've we've recapitulated
which you saw on that you know those
first open field charts once the animals
had been potentially habituated to the
open field but even when we're looking
only at that daytime motion we're still
only measuring a portion of what's
actually observable in those animals so
remember when we go back to the paper
where we were looking at the number of
steps in the MS patients we weren't
looking at the number of steps at night
when they should normally be asleep we
were looking at the number of steps that
they might take during the day so the
question that we then looked at in terms
of this data is are there actually
differences in motion levels at night
when animals are naturally active as we
would hypothesize that that would be the
data that would be most applicable to
what you receive
in the patients with MS and so here I'm
showing you now this is averaged across
the course of that those nine weeks the
night time motion for again those
animals receiving control tower the dark
lines and those animals receiving the
Cooper's own Chow are the blue lines so
prior to the animals receiving Cooper's
own shall we see very similar activity
levels between groups you can see prior
to the Cooper's Chow being given that
increase in night time motion over time
and that actually is associated with
them habituating too and getting used to
the cage but then once we we transfer a
portion of those animals onto Cooper
zone Chow there's a significant decrease
in the overall activity levels starting
even five days after we start moving the
animals on to Cooper's Omochao what's
interesting and you can see that that
goes all the way up until the 14 days
what's interesting is right around those
days where we do the cage changes again
we're inducing novelty to to those
animals we see a return to normal even
in nighttime activity or motion levels
and then as they get used to the K or at
least what we think is as they get used
to the cage other activity levels drop
again and so on and so forth um so as we
think about it you know we really think
that this decrease in the night time
motion that we see not around those cage
changes is probably most directly
translatable or relevant to what you
would see in the human patients with MS
so where's the value than of the digital
biomarkers so some of the areas that I
really that I talked about here were the
traditional measures really only observe
a small portion of what's actually
absorbable so he
what's most relevant is the data at
night after the animals had gotten used
to their environment that the more data
we collect allows us to better
characterize the animal so if you had
followed as we went through looking at
various aspects of the motion data in
the Cooper's own model we actually
nicely recapitulated all of the data
that had been found in the literature in
the open field you would be interesting
to go back and to determine whether or
not you could actually recapitulate
those results in in each of the open
fields but it does suggest that the more
data we get the easier will be for us to
accurately characterize the animal and
know what pieces should directly be
compared when you're thinking about
therapeutics for example and then last
but not least and I think this really
ties from the previous bullet point
which is digital biomarkers which are
acquired under natural conditions are
going to more closely resemble the
predicted responses so when we're not
physically handling the animals or
interacting with the animals we're more
likely to see kind of the natural state
of the animal which in a very sensitive
model like the Cooper zone model where
it's not always easy to get a
reproducible response its these times
where we would expect to see better or
more easily identifiable responses that
we can assess therapeutics against so
the second model that I want to talk
about is predicting pain and stiffness
in rheumatoid arthritis
so again just quickly to go through some
published data in humans with rheumatoid
arthritis or patients with rheumatoid
arthritis I want to show you just on the
next slide a single chart in which
they're looking at the the importance of
being able to monitor the duration of 5
times sit to stand tests in this case
the study the objective of this study
was to demonstrate that the measurements
collected from this 5 times sit to stand
test would enable them to drive an
objective signal related to mourning
pain and stiffness that could be
monitored without actually having to
physically ask the individuals to report
out on their pain and stiffness and more
importantly and they note that in the
clinic it's very challenging to to
actually be able to assess mourning pain
and stiffness because by the time the
patient's actually get into the clinic
that kind of first morning pain has
actually gone away so the question is
can you use one of these digital
biomarkers to be able to be able to
assess that in the home or kind of
natural state of the patient so here
they describe data on 30 participants
the participants were all given one of
these actigraph link devices which looks
like a watch but it actually contains an
accelerometer which can monitor the
speed at which the individual is moving
at any given time so they record
throughout the full 20 days the beep
that the patients have this device as
well as they ask them to do these five
times sit-to-stand
tests a couple of I think I believe they
asked them to do it three times a week
so on Monday Wednesdays and Fridays and
that just involves them crossing the
arms over their chest and then going
from a seated to a standing position
five times they also asked them to
report out pain and stiffness so what
they wanted to do is relate the reported
pain and stiffness to the duration that
it takes them to do these five times six
stand test and hope that they can
actually pull out biomarkers from this
actigraph linked device that would allow
them to basically assess that without
having to get all of this other data so
here's a very challenging graph to read
but in essence what you're seeing here
on the y-axis are those patient reported
scores so the higher the score the more
pain and stiffness the patient reports
and then on the bottom is the normalized
sit-to-stand
test duration so this is the amount of
time that it takes them to do the test
and what you can see is that in general
the more pain that's read out or pain
and stiffness that's reported you see a
longer duration in actually being able
to do this test and so in this paper the
author's talk about the ability to
actually distinguish morning and evening
stiffness and more importantly that
morning stiffness is more severe as
patients report both in the 5 5 times
sit to stand test as well as in what
they can pull out of this actigraph
monitor as well so how does this relate
to rheumatoid arthritis models in the
animals so in this case what I'll show
you here is data from a collagen induced
arthritis model so here we're using a
very standard model in which we give
animals collagen to induce arthritis in
the hind paws of the animals it's one of
the most commonly used models in
rheumatoid arthritis research it nicely
recapitulates disease symptoms and other
features of the disease much like in the
Coopers M model we have an AK LeMay ssin
time period then we induce the animals
through a number
of these injections and then we'll
monitor them over time and and that is
what I show here is the treatment phase
traditionally in a study like this you
would measure a number of different
things you would look at joint thickness
so I'll show you in just a second but
you take calipers and measure the the
ankle size of the animal you might do a
subjective scoring of our thright as'
and you would take those pause and look
at histology and the animals over time
so again while each of these are
important
none of them are directly applicable to
the common kind of outcome measures that
are looked at in the humans in the form
of you know reporting out on pain and
stiffness and whatnot so just looking
quickly at arthritis scores and
thickness measurements so here your
standard assay parameters you would ask
a research associate to go in and to
actually look at the paws of the animals
it's a bit of a small picture but
depending upon how many toes appear to
be inflamed and whether the inflammation
has actually gone up the foot you would
give the animal a different score and
then you would take that same animal and
measure the joint thickness using a pair
of calipers and you can see but that
looks like on the right challenge with
both of these is that they're fairly
subjective and in terms of caliper
measurements one technician may squeeze
a different amount versus another
technician so what I wanted to do is
quickly just show you some data that we
gathered from our own lab so here you
can see joint size measured across the
course of this 17 day study and I'm
showing you two control groups in the
green and the light blue so you can see
really no change in joint thickness
across the full 17 days and then I have
two groups on a group in a b group both
these received collagen but my question
to the audience here is which one
received the more effective drug give
you in one second and then show you that
actually both of them are vehicle
animals so what I really wanted to just
point out here is that research
associate number one took the joint
thickness measurements from the first
set of animals and research associate
number two took joint thickness
measurements on a second set of animals
in a separate study so this just points
out how challenging it is to actually
reproduce across studies and potentially
across technicians trained exactly in
the same way together on the same
measurements in our lab so what we
wanted to do was create an algorithm to
identify the disease without having to
rely on these subjective measurements so
what I'm just showing you on this slide
is a kind of broad strokes overview of
how we actually did that we took from
more than I believe a hundred and fifty
different animals those joint size
measurements as well as the arthritis
scores and histology measurements we
took all of those together as our
expected results for each individual
animal and then we took the the
corresponding motion data and we
extracted a number of different features
from it for example how active was the
animal during the night time how active
were they during the day how fast were
they as examples and we look to see
which of those features best predicts
the expected results so in essence what
we discovered is that the maximum speed
at night actually is the best predictor
of some of the standard measures that
you're looking at histology being a
really important one
arthritis score and and joint
measurements so in essence what we're
showing here is how or what we're saying
is that the the more the arthritis the
animal has the less quickly they can
move
around the cage at night which
remembering back to those patients in
the clinic seems to be a very direct
measure now we're talking about in that
case we were talking about how quickly
could they complete a sit to stand a
test here we're talking about how
quickly they can move around the cage so
on this slide I'm just showing you again
the data you'll notice the joint size
and the arthritis score is identical
from what you saw on this a couple of
slides ago and overlaid on that now in
blue are the digital arthritis index
that we created using this automated
algorithm and I think what's most
telling here is that when you look at
joint size in the arthritis score it
would suggest that the first experiment
had a more severe response than the
second experiment but it actually turns
out that that in reality that that was
reversed so we see more severe histology
in the second experiment than in the
first experiment and the digital
arthritis index that we created
recapitulate that so once we created the
index we actually used this these
digital biomarkers to screen a number of
compounds and this just shows you the
responses from nine of those compounds
that we screened you can see that the
digital earth right that the animals
that received vehicle have no real
change above baseline and that those
blue lines show you improvement over the
vehicle animals that had received the
collagen so those animals that had
arthritis and so animals that received
MC 105 for example MC 110 MC 111 and MC
114 all showed improvements and all of
this data can be found in our
publication in frontiers of pharmacology
but what I really wanted to point out
here is that if you look across all of
the various measures
so here I'm showing you each of the
compounds their total histopathology
score their their score on the digital
arthritis and next inflammation
arthritis and joint size and we rank
order them across those nine compounds
you can see on average all of these rank
order animals in exactly the same way so
MC 105 shows improvement across all of
the various measures the MC 103 appears
to be pretty good across most of them
you know there's some slight differences
as you rank order them across each
measure but there are two compounds that
really stand out as different and I just
want to take two minutes to highlight
these the first is MC 114 and what's
interesting about this compound is that
you see improvements so statistically
they were better than the vehicle when
you think about inflammation arthritis
and joint size but then when you look at
total histopathology score and the
digital arthritis index that would
suggest that there was no statistically
significant improvement
so here the this digital measure of
monitoring arthritis is better at
predicting histopathology than some of
those standard measures in life and the
animal the last one is MC 111 which is
actually quite interesting because
there's no real improvement across any
of the measures histopathology
inflammation arthritis or joint size but
we actually see an improvement in the
digital arthritis index and what's
interesting about this compound is it's
actually a corticosteroid so this one
might actually make sense as well in
this case we're probably relieving the
pain and so we're seeing a fun event
that appears to be functional even
though it's not pathologically improving
so what's what's valuable in this case
about being able to use something like a
digital biomarker
is you can see not only changes in kind
of pathology and overall changes in in
joints in this case but you can actually
see a functional improvement I'm so
taken together we get far more better
interesting data when we take digital
biomarkers and we compare them to
standard biomarkers so just quickly to
go through this this model it's possible
for us to create algorithms to predict
the disease states again between the rat
and the patient with rheumatoid
arthritis we see a similar feature
appears to be very important which is
kind of speed of action the digital
biomarkers are more consistent and
reliable than some of the subjective
scoring techniques and that it allows us
to assess both the functional
consequence and the functional response
so is there an improvement in this case
a pain does the pain reliever have an
improvement even if you don't see an
actual functional improvement so with
that I want to finish by talking about
five key opportunities for digital
biomarkers five kind of things that we
still need to improve on to improve the
use of digital biomarkers in drug
development so the first is around
improving preclinical animal models so
digital biomarkers can be used to
improve the reproducibility and
reliability of our models with the need
to understand less about the source
variability so remember when we talked
about in the Cooper's own model there
were many differences across animal
differences across labs in the response
or even when you talk within a same lab
within the same lab as in our case when
we were looking at the arthritis and the
pothinus but there are a lot of factors
which can lead to you the lack of
reproducibility and that
the more data that we get from the
animals in the form of these digital
biomarkers the less likely we are going
to need to understand all of those
sources of variability because the noise
that's associated with those factors in
essence can be washed away and we can
build ultimately better models that
should be more predictive we're not done
with all of the digital biomarkers so
there's still a need for additional
sensors additional biomarkers that can
be used across preclinical as well as
clinical to track disease so I talked
about a few today ECGs for example and
motion are ones that we have in both
preclinical and clinical but there are a
number of areas where we're unable to
monitor the same things across both and
so there's a need to continue to think
about creating those new digital
biomarkers or potentially being able to
use the same sensors from both human and
an animal and then in addition
clinicians and scientists in the lab as
well as regulatory bodies really need to
work together to validate that those
digital biomarkers are valuable
biomarkers to be looking at across this
this whole spectrum of drug discovery
and development so again there's been a
lot of work from the FDA and the NIH
about thinking about how to validate
those biomarkers across the whole
spectrum now there hasn't been a lot of
work and or there is a lot of work
ongoing and how to validate digital
biomarkers in clinic but we should be
thinking more about broadening that back
into the preclinical phase as well to
really be able to do this effectively we
need to think about collecting digital
biomarkers at scale as well so in our
lab we've collected over a billion hours
of digital metric data on many different
strains of animals my
rats and mice many many different
disease models what we've learned in the
clinic that we need to take back to
preclinical in the clinic the ability to
create these predictive measures has
really only come as we're collecting
more and more of this data from a wider
swath of the population and so what that
really suggests is that the more data we
can collect on our animals in the
preclinical phase the more likely we are
to be able to create these better models
and to be able to translate them or to
understand what is translatable or not
translatable into the clinic and then
the last is really building platforms or
creating platforms that allow us to
build better algorithms through AI so
today I talked a bit about some of the
digital biomarkers associated with
behavioral data and the Cooper's own
model we talked a bit about or we didn't
talk today at all about physiologic data
but we've got data in respiratory and
respiratory function as well I showed
you some data from histology we talked
some about manual observations it's
really not until we can collate and
collect all of that data into one easy
platform that we're going to be able to
create some of the best models through
AI and right now if you look at most
labs manual observations like taking
body weights on a scale or collected
through Excel spreadsheets histology may
live in a completely different program
the digital biomarker data of course or
molecular biomarkers we really need to
be able to integrate all those together
and really and I put it in a separate
color is the clinical data as well so as
we start to work you know more
collaboratively between clinicians and
researchers the preclinical stage how do
we take what we're learning in
Clinic and actually back translate that
into some of the models and potentially
correct or collect more digital
biomarkers but then again of course
translates to translate ability between
preclinical and into the clinic so with
that I'd like to thank you for your time
and attention and thank you thank you
dr. Chaffetz for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May 14 2019 as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we will see you next time bye